Olena et Valentin sont réfugiés dans
leur propre ville depuis 25 ans ils
habitent une maison sur les berges du
Nièvre après la destruction du barrage
ils ont du fuir l'eau est montée
jusqu'au toit ils ont eu deux heures
pour aller constater les dégâts
je suis une femme forte en général
mais là aucun pouvoir aucune force
aucune pensée ne peut me sortir de ce
cauchemar
[Musique]
c'est un cauchemar le toit est tombé le
jardin est retourné il y a de la terre
et de la boue partout jusque là
chez
eux ils étaient à la tête d'un réseau de
partisans des résistances clandestins
voici le même quartier le jour de la
destruction du barrage
ces images ont été tournées par Rolex
leurs voisins
lorsque l'eau était au plus haut il est
allé chercher en bateau des habitants
sur la rive contre les Russes
le front était alors englouti par les
eaux
le premier jour avec les bateaux c'était
possible d'aller chercher les gens
là-bas parce que les Russes étaient
partis ils ont tous laissé il n'y avait
plus un russe sur les îles et donc on a
pu aller là-bas emmener les gens qui
attendaient sur le toit
l'opération n'a été possible que 24
heures Valentin appelle un de ses
contacts sur la rive occupé par les
Russes dans la ville dolleschi cet homme
prend le risque de parler car la
situation est alarmante
c'est effrayant ici vraiment effrayant
les occupants distribuent de l'eau
mais n'en donne qu'aux habitants qui ont
pris le passeport russe
et ils sont revenus sur leurs enseignes
positions
ils sont revenus dans des appartements
qui étaient inondés pas inondés peu
importe
dans la ville il y a des corps de civils
et c'est des civils qui les ramassent
à mesure que le reflux les frappes
russes reprennent de plus belle c'est
des mineurs censés désamorcer des mines
flottantes dans le quartier de Léna et
Valentin Renaud
plusieurs salles de roquettes viennent
d'être retirées depuis la rue
[Musique]